last December the New York Times stunned
readers with the Magnificent snowfall
breathtaking multimedia narrative that
showed the possibilities of long-form
journalism on the web in snowfall John
branch tossed the harrowing story of 16
skiers caught in an avalanche that took
place in February 2012 in the Cascade
Mountains of Washington State it's a
six-part story accompanied by
interactive graphics video and character
buyers of the skiers and snowboarders
caught in the avalanche the story was
widely hailed as the future of online
reading The Times's first board leap
into experience based feature it was
also the times's first foray into the
e-publishing of long-form singles
snowfall as you can see here opens with
this otherworldly video loop of snow
blowing across a mountain slope then
comes the text beginning with an
action-packed lead that foreshadows what
comes next story of suspense and
heartbreak toured with perfect pacing
and in riveting detail but snowfall is
not just a well-told story it's also in
the world in the words of the New Yorker
an investigation to the hazards of group
decision making and the insidious role
that peer pressure the fellow to
Authority and presumption of expertise
can play in undermining intelligence and
experience to report this story John
Branch interviewed every survivor
researched the world of backcountry
skiing traveled to Alaska to speak with
snow scientists read accident reports
and even hiked the terrain himself what
makes this story so powerful is the
recollection in their own words of each
of the skiers times has short video
experts of each of them one of them
Elise sucks that says this memorable
line it was like being in a washing
machine I didn't know which way was up
which way was down is this the way I am
going to die avalanche has 15 thousand
words generated 1,100 comments
online and readers spent an average of
12 minutes on the story a record and the
internet of short attention spans it was
also published in a 14-page special
section of the newspaper The Times does
have a newspaper and two days before
Christmas last year so John branch how
did you find this story oh well thank
you um you know I didn't know about this
when it happened and I got a call
probably two months later when it did
happen we assigned a freelancer based in
colorado to write a story in fact this
avalanche happened at the same on the
same day as another fatal avalanche in
washington and so the freelancer wrote a
very x ian a one story that said these
two avalanches on sunday in Washington
are part of a bigger picture you know
you can sort of can sort of picture the
lead that we typically put on these
things part of a bigger bigger picture
of avalanches that have proven deadly
this winter at that point there had been
a number higher number than usual of
avalanche desk and so it was a next day
kind of story and about two months later
I got a call from my editor who said do
you remember that story that Avalanche
and I said yeah not really and he said
and you know what I think there's
something more there you know if indeed
more and more people are headed to the
backcountry enticed by changes in
equipment enticed by open gate policies
of ski areas and if indeed more people
are dying in avalanches there's gotta be
a way to look at this in a different way
not just the next day kind of way and so
we talked about it and I think we both
came to the pretty quick conclusion that
the best way to do that would be to
shine maybe a very narrow beam onto the
broader issue and I loved it the work
you guys did as big of an issue as
pipelines are your story is probably
much more interesting focus on one
pipeline and in part on one person as
opposed to let's do a big story of
pipelines around the world so sort of
with that same mantra in mind we said
let's find an avalanche and it became
pretty clear that the one in tunnel
creek was probably the one to do because
not only
was it the most deadly of the season it
was also one in which there were a lot
of survivors and witnesses and most
avalanches kill the people that set them
off and they don't have a lot of
witnesses so it's one thing to find an
avalanche it's another thing to report
it how do you report on an avalanche
that took place in you know like several
months after before you even even
thought there was a story there yeah
nothing like reporting a story on
avalanches in the middle of the summer
the first thing I did was besides doing
some very basic going back and see what
was written about this was to make a
couple calls to people who were in the
Avalanche and I'd started calling them
and I didn't know what kind of response
i would get certainly it had been two or
three months since the Avalanche I would
assume that they were tired of thinking
about it talking about it they didn't
know me from anybody and here's another
guy just another reporter calling him
saying hey I got to talk to you again
can we go over it all again and
fortunately on the first two calls were
making Michelson and John snifter both
of them are actually members of the
media and they've responded to my
request within an hour or two and I had
a both my phone for several hours each
going minute by minute through what
happened that day and you know at the
time I assume that I would be able to
get hopefully a few people to talk about
the Avalanche but I'm very proud of the
fact that in the end all of them we
figure out who was there which was a
trick in its own and in the end they all
spoke but I do think it it took a
certain amount of trust and it certainly
this is a horrible analogy snowball to
some extent that i talked to them and
when I went to make the next call for
the next person they were certainly
calling them and saying hey Megan what
do you think of this guy you know I
don't want to talk about this again what
do you think this guy and fortunately
over the course of a couple months they
all agreed to talk so how do you talk
about something you know tragic like
this how do you even begin in the
conversation you know the thing I did
with them is just ask them if they would
just walk me through the guitar OH
weekend I believe it happened on a
Sunday and so I said you know why are
you there at stevens pass
you know tell me when you got there
Thursday Friday what were you doing walk
me through Saturday when in really
minute by minute and it was a little bit
excruciating for some of them to really
kind of recall everything that led up to
the event but one of my first missions
was to was to sort of build a timeline
of what happened you know after you get
10 or 12 or 13 people talking about the
same event I was trying to think well if
you guys left that group at what point
of the Avalanche occur where were you
when this happened it became a little
bit of a feat in trying to really figure
out chronologically exactly where people
were on the mountain at exactly what
time there were some GoPro camera
footage there wasn't GoPro camera
footage there were text messages there
were 911 calls there were some ways I
could sort of construct a timeline and
that's what I did first is basically
took all the information from the
interviews and cut and pasted all their
quotes about what they were doing each
moment and cut it into a huge file so
your chronology was minute by minute was
it that's close to me in five minutes
possible yeah and once they actually at
lunch yes so the interviews were all
very very detailed I want to know every
minute by minute what happened but you
did more than interviewing you did other
things to get this story done you even
went to an international snow science
workshop yeah which I didn't know that
existed the at the International snow
science workshop which I missed in
Grenoble France recently I don't know
why I didn't get to go to the next one
was an anchorage last year and there are
700 or 800 snow scientists from around
the world that convene it's it's an
entire world unto its own it's not all
people who are interested in backcountry
skiers a lot of them are people who are
into construction of railroads and
highways and people who are town
planners in mountain communities who are
trying to figure out can we build here
or we just setting ourselves up for
danger it's a fascinating world yeah
they did spend four or five days and
that's a conference and then you climb
the same mountain well yeah what was
interesting is that where this avalanche
took place is
was really difficult to get to you know
you can't get to it in the summer his
lips aren't running for one thing but
the ski area at one point did let me did
open up the lift for me and I went down
there with two guys we went to the top
hiked up to where the top were these
guys and then we hiked down as far as we
could down into the ravine and
separately i started at the bottom hiked
up from the bottom i really just want to
get a sense of the terrain and it's
brutal I mean it was from Colorado I
think I know mountains a little bit and
it was really difficult treacherous
terrain and it really was kind of a
funnel I'm you can sort of see both the
allure of it because it's beautiful but
also the treachery of it so this project
took six months a team of multimedia and
visual journalists 14 14 pages fifteen
thousand words that's a lot I mean is it
this I mean I don't mean this is this is
it a bit of overkill absolutely oh you
know what we get that question a lot and
I I'm probably wrong person answer it
you know when I started it was go check
out do a story about an avalanche it
began very organically Steve will I
think talk about the senior of you in a
few minutes knows that I basically took
this file of interviews that I had that
it were all basically cut and spliced
into a chronological story or a
chronological thing of 30,000 words and
at some point I went to my editor and
said just in case you were wondering if
I've been busy last few weeks I sort of
felt guilty like they haven't heard from
you in weeks and I've sent them that
file and they read through it and they
actually for a time thought we can
almost run this just nothing but people
talking about um it was 30,000 words
that would been a little much but anyway
they passed that file which is kind of
unusual for us they pass it on to other
departments including Steve including
the video department or our photo editor
and said hey John branch is working on
this we think there's something
potentially powerful and and we're going
to go pretty big on this we think are
you guys interested in
Steve's great credit Steve said yes of
course we'll do it okay Steve why don't
you come up and show us how you did it
take us behind the scenes of snowfall
okay so I'll just run through the
presentation of it give you a little bit
of the backstory it does start with this
kind of signature moving still was one
of a series of short videos that
Katherine Spangler edited she was the
main video editor on the piece and so
with the the top of the piece we just
try to keep things as minimal as
possible you don't see navigation until
you scroll down a little bit and the the
general idea was just to push the
multimedia as close as possible to the
words here we'll see at least talk for a
little bit I had no ability to control
what was happening to me like I was
being tossed over and over and over it
was like being in a washing machine I
didn't know which way was up I didn't
know which way was down I couldn't see
anything there were times when I
couldn't breathe because there were so
much snow and there was a just like void
of air I definitely thought that after
being continent for a little while holy
moly this this may be the end like I
this is it this is are you serious this
is really the way I'm going to to die so
then you continue to scroll and you kind
of get to this section that is really I
think one of the better moments where
the browser starts to darken and you're
reading about the Cascade Mountain Range
and then you're in the Cascade Mountain
Range and this is a motion graphic
created by a member of the graphics
department Jeremy white it's just a
digital elevation model that he
extruded and then he draped satellite
imagery over that and there was some
other effects he applied to it and then
he created the animation but this sort
of merging of in the words with
multimedia is really the the main sort
of conceptual leap and it started you
know here
from a simple idea so those black
horizontal bars represent multimedia
elements and and the vertical bars
represent words and you know it was a
little bit of a leap because ordinarily
we you know this is how we present
multimedia there's a written story and
then there are you know what some people
refer to as bells and whistles we don't
refer to them that way you know along
the side but they're separate you know
no matter how compelling the multimedia
elements are there there unto themselves
and not part of what people in the
newsroom talk about as the story so the
idea here was to not have separate
stories but have one story and to create
you know only multimedia where it was
going to be you know function as
connective tissue between sections of
John's story and so I'll show you
another another part of the piece starts
out with another removing still and then
here we show you a reconstruct basically
of the Avalanche it was something that
we created from data actually so we show
you where the skiers were on the
mountain
and include some contour lines and so we
added a little sound to sound actually
is there's a little data component of
the sound is ticking off every time it
it crosses another hundred feet a little
annotation on the speed so you get the
idea and you know it started with with
this actually I think the source we
worked with with someone John found was
us the Swiss group that does Avalanche
research and they they do modeling of
avalanches and we had a lot of
information you know the physical
attributes of this we had that sort of
width of the crack and the depth and we
had this very detailed elevation model
so we knew the slope and variations in
the slope and so we passed them our data
and the model that we created and they
started to actually create a animation
out of it and so they gave us the
velocity and the height of this at
different at different positions down
the slope of the mountain and then we
mapped that to our 3d model you can sort
of see the stages of it here and then we
started to kind of style eyes it and
simplify it so that it became something
that was understandable and then we you
know included scales and annotation to
make it a little bit more meaningful
that was it
thank you so we'll take a few minutes of
questions in avalanche and then open it
up to all the entire panel all right
there's an avalanche of questioners here
yes please go ahead hi Jenny again and
yeah of course everyone saw this when it
came out and people are still continue
to talk about it simply because we
haven't seen it duplicated yet can you
talk to us a little bit about maybe
Steve what are the challenges costs
associated with everything that goes
into making a project like this and why
maybe it is such a special thing right
now and you know we haven't seen
something like this since last December
well there were a lot of challenges
although at the time it didn't seem that
difficult we had a lot of time to work
on it there was no real peg and we kind
of kept pushing back the publication
date because we were developing assets
and you know became more and more
confident that they were going to be
good and that we had a good idea for how
we were going to put it all together I
think you know the challenge in
repeating is that you know we turn
around stories pretty quickly even
stories that have a lot of people
working on them even stories where were
you know creating a lot of multimedia
and you know with this piece it was sort
of a luxury to have the amount of time
that we did and so it led us you know
try things out and and have those things
not work and with other projects we're
having to turn them around so quickly
that it's hard to experiment the degree
that we did with with this project yes
and that's it I have absolutely no
digital training and I'm a reporter but
every time I look at this project I
wonder what did John branch do and I see
that there was a huge team that was
supporting him but as far as we are
concerned when there is this growing you
know concern about being a one-man army
and
able to produce something like this what
what can you do what can the skills can
you learn just produce something as
terrific as that and yeah how do you go
about it well I mean there were maybe a
dozen people working on this so you know
there was a video editor there was a
photographer Ruth crimson great
photographer there were 3d modelers and
animators you know which which path
would you like to go down I mean the and
you know of course it's it was all tied
to what John was doing I mean that none
of this would have happened if you know
we didn't have a great story um we you
know if there wasn't a sort of openness
that John had with his reporting you
know the sort of raw reporting that he
opened up and gave us a start creating
some of the multimedia elements I think
I was like a crucial things so uh you
know as a reporter certainly one thing
to take on in thinking about how these
things become possible is to not be so
guarded about material and that there
are others who can contribute you know
elements that will that will you know
improve the quality of the piece of
ultimately I've sort of joke that you
should probably try to be boring like 10
years later because if you can help it
because uh I'd imagine these some of
these graphics that took days or weeks
to construct in 10 years might take a
shift and maybe people they'll be so
easy in some way I mean I think will
laugh at you know we'll look at that
this and kind of laugh I got long it
took and how every seemed to love it at
the time and now it'll it'll look it'll
acquaint at some point it's hard that my
me to believe yeah but no doubt I think
with technology and Steve knows better
than anybody i think it's changing so
quickly that people will be able to do
this kind of thing probably sooner than
we realize i have two quick questions
one is when you were sort of building
narrative and actually structuring the
beasts online what was the ideation
behind
doing certain multimedia elements at a
certain place I thought that was quite
interesting in terms of how the the
enticing was curated so just just
something on that and the second thing
is is the idea sort of this being touted
as the model for for multimedia
journalism going forward six months I
don't know 15 people I don't know how
much money was spent on it it's
something pretty much the New York Times
or The Washington Post can before I
don't think most of the other newspapers
here I can't afford to put that sort of
resource given that do you having
created this really think this is the
model for multimedia journalism going
ahead so I'll just answer your first
question you can just give you a little
back story when we started to talk about
the multimedia for the project I mean we
when we when we launched we behave the
way that we ordinarily do we wanted to
make a model of the mountain we thought
there was a graphic that we be that
would be separate from John's piece that
we would make some kind of a simulation
of the recreation of the Avalanche and
you know we started to see video and
some of the photography and and the the
models the graphics that we were making
started to improve and we kind of
realized that they they were going to be
pretty strong and started to talk about
what we were going to do with all of
this material and you know the idea
service that we would try to bring them
all together and and we thought that
meant you know changing some of the
written story that we would want the
multimedia to be like to be like
connective tissue to be a part of the
story and so we sort of presented this
idea to joe sexton who was the sports
editor and Jason sulman who's who is now
the sports editor and said look you know
in order for this to work in order to
bring all of this together and make it
means editing it means us editing the
multimedia so that it so that it so that
when you experience it it is like
reading and it means us editing your
words so that they they lead you into
the multimedia
natural way and Joe section said no way
that was it and so then it took a couple
of weeks you know to let him Mull it
over and I think ultimately I don't even
know how he became convinced that it was
maybe a good idea but he said yes and
then in the end we actually didn't end
up changing any of John's words you know
we got a draft and and the stuff that we
were the pieces we were making fell in
line sort of just right in different
places and and it became obvious where
to put things because of the way John
you know structured the narrative things
just seemed they were logical they they
were a good fit in different places and
I don't know if you want to talk about
that is this a modular system no society
so I think it I mean snowfall is not
really a model I mean the way that we
made that project is not has not been a
model really for projects that are sort
of similar that we have done since I
mean except the idea you know there this
year we've run projects on you know
there was a there was a science piece on
on the the quest find the Higgs boson
and there has been a series by libby
rosenthal about the cost of you know
health care in this country and we did a
piece recently a reporter to trip from
st. Petersburg to Moscow and sort of
documented her you know story when she
found along the way in a similar way and
it was at a lower scale and so we're
turning on this idea of bringing a
multimedia into the written piece and
and editing the multimedia so that it is
not sort of take you on a tangent and
and also thinking about seriously you
know talking about and at times doing it
X you know changing the the written
story so that can accommodate ability
that those are the lasting you know sort
of effects so in terms of it being a
model it has become sort of a model but
not the level of production
the snowfall in it so that side please
John you said your editor assigned you
to this story but can you talk a little
bit about finding a story that already
has been done and identifying that there
really is a lot more there and how to
report on it in a way that is that we
still care and that's not repetitive
yeah your ex it have been done and in
fact during the reporting for this i
found out that Megan was writing a
first-person account and of course you
know at this point multimedia might have
been involved and I said great we're
going to be writing a story that we have
nothing that we are going to try to
report months later and meanwhile
there's gonna be a first-person account
in Outside magazine of soompi was
actually there how am I going to compete
with that do I think that the the key
was that we were going to kind of go
deep it's another Avalanche cliche um
metaphor we're we're willing to do more
than just a new story we really were
invested in doing you know we want to
know the emotions we don't know exactly
how it all came together we wanted to
weave together 16 it turns out to be 16
different stories basically and try to
weave them together there aren't a lot
of news organizations that are probably
to do that 17 i think it was closer to
seventeen thousand words and there was
some debate in the newsroom whether it's
actually the longest story single story
that the times has ever run you don't go
into a story thinking it's gonna be
seventeen thousand words but it just
sort of evolved that way and and i think
that's kind of the key here is that we
didn't have any preconceived notions
with a story or with the multimedia this
all just heard of grew and you use that
word again it really did snowball it's
like this is good and fortunately there
were editors in Stevie and one and Joe
Septon being one and Jason Stallman and
in ultimately Jill Abramson who said
this is so good we're not going to mess
with it keep going yes peace this is a
question more for John and you've
touched on this a little bit I think in
some of your responses but I was
wondering if you could talk having gone
through this project if or how that has
affected your compositional
or how you think about a story having
had your text you know become the basis
for this much bigger collaborative
multimedia project than had been seen
before you know the short answer is that
it didn't I had written most of this you
know I had that huge kind of
chronological draft of all the
interviews and I use that as kind of the
as kind of a skeleton for I've built a
story in the end I ended up doing it
mostly chronological so in some ways
don't tell the poultry board this this
was kind of easy to write once I had all
that reporting done because it was kind
of chronological to follow what I'd
already had already kind of constructed
with the reporting there was I did get
the phone call I live in California now
I did get the phone call from Jason
Stallman saying you just missed an
interesting meeting steve says steve
says you got to trust us we want to
build these multimedia components what
it might mean is that you might need a
train change from the transitions we
might need to cut some of John's text
and try to make it all work so that the
graphic elements basically replaced the
words it's all gonna be one blended
thing to which joe sexton I I can't
believe he said something without a lot
of swear words but um and so he baits we
had my back and so there was discussion
whether or not we were going to really
blend and sort of make and have the
writer write this differently because of
multimedia in the end nothing changed I
don't know if that's happened since then
I'm involved in a couple projects now
that I could potentially see we would
write it before the multimedia yeah that
was my question is like how does it
change your compositional process now it
hasn't I'm working on something now see
if I were talking about before this that
I could see I'll go into a writing it
you know maybe it's a bunch of vignettes
and I'm picturing how it would work in
multimedia as opposed to one long
narrative I think we're right at that
cusp I think this is an interesting time
because as a reporter's I think we are
now you know I've always thought about
how would you know what we do to add
video to this or a photographer what
kind of graphics would be useful in this
but as Steve showed that used to be
separate little things and now we're
blending them together you have to think
about
going to work out and I think we're kind
of at that point and opie interesting to
see over next what five or ten years as
more and more reporters sort of get told
guess what your text is changing because
of whatever and there was talk early on
not to be labor the point but there was
talk early on for example about whether
some of my quotes go to get cut some of
the quotes forget cut in favor of that
person actually talking and I think
we're not quite there yet with all of a
sudden somebody's head popping up and
and I don't know you notice he still
have to click on me on the play buttons
and I think you know maybe the readers
not quite ready to have somebody to
suddenly start talking or maybe you
don't have the volume turned up you know
but those are the kinds of kinds of
discussions that we're having Julian
there's a quote making the rounds among
the executive classes of the media that
this project costs damn near a million
dollars and because of that times would
never do anything this extensive again
I'm not going to ask you to verify that
quote or not but can you talk about the
lessons that you learned both of you
from doing this and how you're applying
it to the projects that you're working
on now that do involve multi medium I
don't see how it costs that much I mean
I mean this is going on well so the
group that that built the the project on
the web did not work on this exclusively
I mean there were other projects that we
were juggling it was 2012 so we had a
presidential election and there were a
lot of news events we had to cover as
well so it wasn't something that we were
we weren't just spending our time
working on this yeah if there's one
regret I have in terms of a line in the
story it's actually the PostScript which
said 16 people worked on this for six
months some of those people worked on it
for a few days some people will do off
and on over the course of a couple
months I was probably only one that was
involved for to some degree for six
months under me to cut you off but
unfortunately we happen to work
someplace where we didn't the two of us
at least didn't have to worry about the
cost of it somebody above us did I don't
know we maybe just didn't tell them what
we were doing I don't know exactly how
it all worked out I don't think
anybody's added up how much did this
cost I don't know if there's a way to
add that up
and I certainly know that we are not
going to try to write stories to make
money you know we see this in a much
broader picture than that you know if
you had to go out and sell a story to
make money for the New York Times most
of our stories would not get written so
the lessons learned i think extend
beyond the graphics department or the
video desk of the photo desk to the
newsroom generally i mean it goes back
to what John was saying or he's now
thinking about stories a little bit
differently I think the project and some
of the some similar projects that we've
done since then have caused reporters to
want to be involved in the creation of
visual elements and and has you know
generated discussion around the newsroom
about how you know the value of those
elements and so I think the the lessons
learn are just sort of shift in the
culture the newsroom so there's not
we're still obviously going to be
generating thousands and thousands of
words near times but you know I think
there's going to be a lot more
consideration sort of given to the value
of visual sort of interactive journalism
going forward yes you just talked about
you just said that you don't write
stories to make money which is kind of a
comfortable position you put yourself
and because if small newsrooms want to
tell long-form in multi media stories
they need to make money and I wondered
if you at any point talked about
advertisement generating advertisement
revenue because I think advertisement
would kind of decreased quality of the
piece and so I mean there's the model of
the edifice has for you pay per article
what other ways could you think of a
what do you think or possible to make
those stories on generate money and do
to finance them
yeah my point about the money I want to
be clear is that I don't think we would
be in a good position if we set out to
write a story and this individual story
needs to make money that's probably on a
story most people want to read it's this
you know I'd hope to think that we would
like to look at it in a bigger picture
where the collection of stories that we
produce will get subscribers will get
advertisers that sort of thing it was
interesting and Steve prabhas more about
this than I do but it was interesting to
have a meeting with their new publisher
shortly after snowfall came out there
was there were discussions during the
making of this about advertising and
whether advertising should be sprinkled
in in the end there what for just a few
ads there's a few ads that kind of go
across two weeks later we had a meeting
with the publisher and our new CEO Mark
Thompson and we were talking about all
this and he said you guys I loved it on
the new CEO absolutely loved what you
did but why in the hell did you guys put
ads in it which is not something you
would think a CEO and say but his point
was there should but you know maybe we
gummed it up a little bit you had
something beautiful and maybe we
shouldn't have done that maybe there's a
different way to look at it maybe we
could have sold a sponsorship for it or
maybe you just have what might be a loss
leader this is going to bring attention
positive attention to the new york times
it will get subscribers in that way you
won't actually see the money no
accountant can figure out how much money
did this cost and how much did it make
so we didn't just mention that we did
run a long-form piece this summer about
it was a profile of a jockey and that
piece was sponsored by BMW but the
people generating the piece didn't have
a lot to do with selling the article I
mean it's not our jobs to sell it it's
our jobs to make the stories